- Depuis lundi, beau temps,
de Pékinois doivent faire
la file pour se faire test
À part ces centres de dépistage,
les lieux publics sont
culturelles annulées
et les écoles seronttetetes
fermées à compter de demain.
FRÉDÉRIC LEMAÎTRE, correspondant
- Et là, les vols ont été
annulés, lrararains ont été
annulés et les gens ne peuvent
pas quit
d'ailleurs la même situation
dansnononombreuses autres
villes. Donc, voilà, la ville
au ralenti.- - - Cet isolement e
pourrait s'intensifier dès
des derniers jours confirme une
augmentation des cas de COVID.
ROXANE BORGÈS DA SILVA, prof.,
- Actuellement, la stratégie
du gouvernement chinois serait
de confiner la ville de Pékin
au complet, ce qui va avoir
un énorme impact économique,
social et, comme je vous
le disais, sur la santé mentale.
- Depuis deux ans, la stratégie
zéro COVID avait permis
à la Chine de limiter de façon
spectaculaire le nombre de cas
et de décès liés au coronavirus.
Ce n'est plus le cas avec les
variants Omicron, beaucoup plus
contagieux que les précédents.
Les Chinois sont aujourd'hui
plus vulnérables, parce qu'ils
sont beaucoup moins vaccinés.
- Pourquoi est-ce que il n'y a
pas eu de priorité accordée
à la vaccination? Simplement
parce qu'on se rend compte que
les vaccins chinois sont assez
peu efficaces et que la Chine
ne veut pas, pour des raisons,
disons-le, nationalistes,
importer des vaccins étrangers.
- Même avec ce vaccin-là,
qui est moins efficace,
ça a quand même permis,
dans une certaine mesure,
de réduire la circulation
du virus et, surto
de réduire le développement
de symptômes graves
et donc d'hospitalisations.
- Les scèneososososos et
de colère qu'on voit à Shanghai,
qui est strictement confinée
depuis un mois, pourraient-elles
se répéter à Pékin?
- Jusqu'à présent, il y avait un
soutien massif de la population
à la politique du gouvernement,
la politique sanitaire
du gouvernement.
Les gens avaient peur du COVID.
Maintenant, ils commencent
à avoir peur de la politique
du gouvernement face au COVID.
Ce sera un tel symbole,
si Pékin, la capitale Pékin et
le siège du pouvoir du Parti
communiste, était totalement
confiné, alors que le reste
du monde vit normalement,
ce serait le symbole d'un tel
échec, que ça pourrait avoir
des conséquences politiques
au niveau international
et au niveau national.
- Avec une cinquantaine
de villes confinées et
des milliers d'usines fermées,
les conséquences économiques
sont déjà catastrophiques.- - -e
économique du pays qui est
bloquée pendant un mois,
y compris avec le port
de Shanghaï, qui est un des plus
grands ports, voire le plus
grand port du monde, c'est
évident que tout est bloqué.
Il est évident que si
Pékin était confiné, même
si Shanghaï rouvre peu à peu,
la mécanique se bloquera.
- La crainte d'une récession
pourrait peut-être
convaincre le Parti communiste
à ne pas confiner Pékin.
Ici Sophie Langlois,
Radio-Canada, Montréa